Someone please tell me why I woke up at 4 a m.
And decided to make rice pudding
when I had a flight to catch.
Not even two hours later,
I woke up craving this German breakfast merchandise.
So I decided to make that right when I woke up,
alongside a cup of peppermint tea.
Today is travel day.
I have a shoot in New York.
He decided to tag along.
So we're gonna have three days in New York.
I'm really excited for that.
I went back upstairs
and ran the shower for lucky to get him out of bed.
He was telling me about this crazy dream
he had last night.
Lately we've both had really vivid dreams.
It's really weird
cause usually I don't dream.
I did my skincare and then my hair.
I always leave my toiletries out
cause I need them that same morning.
So I packed those up really quick
and then decided to get dressed in the morning.
My brain doesn't work properly,
so I lay my outfit out the night before
and make sure that super warm and cozy.
I walk downstairs because something was burning
and I realized I burnt my rice pudding.
So I never ate that.
At this point,
we were rushing to the airport
and needed to check in our bag.
Also, if you can get clear,
it's so easy and quick to get through security.
Highly recommend.
We made it onto our plane and landed in New York
three hours Later.
It feels so good being back.
I love the energy,
the people, the walking,
just everything about it.
We decided to get ready really quick
and then go have some lunch.